comment allez vous la dernière fois où
c'était la fois d'avant bon en tout cas
parmi les 32 dernières vidéos histoire
il y en a une qui était une histoire de
survie qui a raconté l'histoire d'un mec
a survécu sur son radeau de sauvetage
pendant deux mois tout seul au milieu de
la mer et j'ai adoré ça pour deux
raisons la première c'est de voir
comment il a fait pour survivre sachant
que moi je pense que je ne tiens pas
deux jours à sa place et la deuxième
c'est aussi de voir un peu l'impact
psychologique que ça et ce qui se passe
un peu dans ton cerveau humain quand tu
es un niveau de détresse aussi venerque
ont été aussi proche finalement de
mourir alors des histoires comme ça il
en existe plein mais y en a une qui a
attiré mon attention
récemment cette fois ça se passe pas en
mer ça se passe en antarctique vous
savez le continent il ya que des
scientifiques parce que c'est invivable
aujourd'hui je vais vous raconter
l'expédition cauchemardesque d'un très
célèbre explorateur australien qui
s'appelle cirque douglas mawson et
croyez moi si vous avez déjà un peu peur
des conditions extrêmes du froid et où
après cette vidéo vous détesterez encore
plus douglas mawson né en 1892 en
angleterre mais attention il poursuit sa
vie à sydney en australie devient donc
australien voilà je vais pas raconter
deux histoires de suite où ça concerne
des anglais ça va on peut savoir que lui
son truc c'est les sciences c'est
vraiment sa passion et d'ailleurs il va
en faire ses études puisqu'il va faire
des études de géologie et d'ingénierie
en 1903 après ses études il participe à
une expédition géologique au vanuatu
tout naturellement c'est lui donne envie
d'en faire plus et quatre ans plus tard
vu qu'il a kiffé l'île paradisiaque il
décide de faire une expédition à un
endroit opposé à une île paradisiaque
une expédition en antarctique pourquoi
il est amené à faire cette expédition là
parce qu'à l'époque toutes les nations
elles se livrent une méga compétition il
ya une sorte de méga concours de [ __ ]
et en gros c'est celui qui aura exploré
le plus de terre en antarctique qu'iliad
du coup ceux qui sont très aller risquer
leur vie là bas parce que c'est des
conditions vraiment extrêmes ils sont
grassement payés par le gouvernement à
tel point que les explorateurs qui vont
là bas on les appelle les héros de
l'antarctique et le bon douglas
évidemment il veut sa part du gâteau il
rejoint l'expédition nimrod en 1907 et
il fait partie des premiers homme à
atteindre le pôle sud magnétique et
c'est aussi l'un des premiers hommes à
gravir le mont erebus un volcan de 3800
mètres le plus au sud de la terre beau
gosse il est donc en 1910 invités à
participer à l'expédition terra nova qui
a pour but d'atteindre le pôle sud
géographique je connais super bien la
différence entre les deux mais on n'a
pas le temps on va passer à l'est on
parle d'une expédition colossal et les
participants c'est que des gros noms du
explorateurs guen douglas refuse
pourquoi parce que c'est douglas mon
pote et douglas il veut monter sa propre
expédition là vous vous dites sûrement
comme moi quand j'ai lu ça [ __ ] légaux
du mec fait la l'expédition qui tu
racontes là euh je ferme mon truc et
bien sachez un truc refusé de participer
à cette expédition ça lui a tout
simplement sauvé la vie tout le monde
est mort dans cette expédition
l'expédition terra nova c'était un échec
non seulement parce que tout le monde
est mort au moment du retour mais aussi
parce que en arrivant sur place il y
avait des norvégiens qui était déjà
arrivé 30 jours avant
j'écoute explorer pas des terres jamais
visité par l'homme d'explorer un truc
visité par des norvégiens 30 jours plus
tôt ce qui est beaucoup moins
prestigieux bref on né en 1911 et
douglas et commence à planifier son
expédition l'expédition australasienne
de l'antarctique le nom est pas ouf
soyons d'être son but est simple un peu
comme toutes les expéditions des pokes
et mener des missions scientifiques et
cartographié landreau et aussi tant qu'à
faire il revendiquait des territoires
pour l'australie on sait jamais voir
douglas comme youtube heures et streamer
préféré a donc besoin de trouver des
sponsors mais il va passer à sponsoriser
pardon vpn rivaux children il réussit je
sais pas comment à se faire financer par
le roi d'angleterre directement mais
aussi le gouvernement australien au cas
où en back up et aussi quelques
compagnies minières il réunit donc une
somme d'argent importante grâce à
laquelle il va pouvoir s'entourer de 90
personnes c'est 90 personnes ça donnera
cinq groupes de personnes différentes
qui mèneront chacun une expédition
différentes sur place et douglas pour
son groupe y choisit que deux personnes
moi j'en aurais pris genre 22 pour être
sûrs d'être bien le premier c'est le
lieutenant bellegrave ninis fusillé
royal anglais qui étaient déjà là lors
de l'expédition nimrod que douglas a
fait le deuxième homme c'est xavier
mertz un champion olympique de ski ça a
du sens attendait parce que sur place
ils vont se déplacer en traîneau le
traîneau ses proches du ski douglas va
charger ce champion olympique de ski de
s'occuper des 48e ski qui traîneront les
traîneaux pendant l'expédition ça saoule
mais qu'il a même pas un chien chez lui
il doit s'occuper de 48 bref on a les
hommes les chiens le matériel le bateau
lors aura un ancien bateau de chasse à
la baleine habitué aux eaux glaciales et
le départ est prévu pour le 28 juillet
1911 le voyage dure en
cinq mois les gars nous on est lessivé
après avoir pris le train ou l'avion
trois heures sur place première étape
évidemment créer un abri une base dans
laquelle passer l'hiver cette base ils
vont l'appeler le cap denison en honneur
aux plus gros parent d'expédition young
denizo ce style est un peu genre tu
finances des expéditions et du coup il
ya des bases en ton nom je vous arrête
tout de suite le cap denison c'est à
chier en gros le camp ils l'ont fait un
endroit qui est considéré comme l'un des
endroits où il ya le plus de vent au
monde il ya des rafales mon pass pas des
rafales de vent c'est des rafales
d'accueil 47 et surtout souvenez vous on
est en antarctique en plein hiver les
températures on est sûrs en moyenne
entre -10 et moins 60 degrés il ya beau
avoir des huskys mignon et plein de gens
c'est quand même pas la fête du slip et
construisent donc plein de buts pour
accommoder tout le monde est dans ces
huttes il fait 4 2 comme si la vous
décidiez de passer la nuit dans votre
frigo c'est peut-être bon pour la peau
mais pas pour l'esprit bref nous sommes
le 10 novembre 1912 les cinq groupes
sont maintenant formés et par tous dans
des directions différentes tout le monde
doit être de retour maximum le 15
janvier 1913 parce que c'est tout
simplement la date où le bateau le roja
se casse et ya une raison à ça c'est que
l'eau risque de nouveau de forme et de
la glace glace qui va bloquer le bateau
est malheureusement ils n'ont pas assez
de vivres pour passer des mois tous
ensemble ici avant de pouvoir repartir
l'info est bien retenue et tout le monde
part avec l'ambition de revenir en héros
douglas xavier ninis parts plein est
leur objectif est simple ils doivent
attendre une zone qui s'appelle hôtes et
qui à 500 km de la base pendant cinq
semaines tout se passe bien ils font des
relevés scientifiques et s'habituer aux
terrains qui les entoure et la premier
problème parmi les chiens qu'ils ont
emmené se trouvent deux femelles qui
mettent bas et évidemment vu les
conditions ils peuvent pas s'occuper des
portes et après une longue réflexion
douglas va tout simplement tuer les
chiots et les donner à manger aux autres
chiens sauf que c'est un moment horrible
pour les trois hommes et encore plus
pour nine et c'est xavier qui était
vraiment attachés aux chiens cher je
vous le rappelle avec qui ils ont fait
le trajet de cinq mois sur le bateau il
avait rien d'autre à [ __ ] que des
caresser les chiens et puis les jours
passent et nouveaux problèmes encore
plus chiant l'expédition devient
beaucoup plus périlleuse que prévu en
gros le quotidien de nos trois amis ces
deux marchés sauf qu'en antarctique il
ya plein de crevasses des crevasses et
des trous d'un coup dans le sol qui
peuvent faire jusqu'à 50 mètres de
profondeur en gros tu tombes de danse et
ciao merci pour ta contribution au
revoir le souci c'est qu'à cause de la
neige il est très dur de repérer les
crevasses qu'est ce que vous dites c'est
ça nouveau problème le lieutenant diniz
devient temporairement aveugle à cause
des puissants reflets du soleil sur la
neige en gros la la rétine sensible et
le soleil tape tellement fort que ça lui
cram la rétine et comme on antarctic
tout est blanc et tout reflète le soleil
peu importe où et regarde il est baisé
vu la dangerosité du terrain sur lequel
ils avancent c'est un peu roule on va
pas se mentir et aussi il a quelques
doigts qui gèle et donc de temps en
temps de glace de lyon d'un sixième
partie comme ça un quotidien tout à fait
normal mais ça ne suffit pas il leur
faut encore plus de problèmes un jour
l'un des trois traîneaux qu'ils
transportent avec eux tombent dans une
crevasse il est malheureusement
irrécupérables et la douglas prend une
décision malines il se dit bon ce truc
des crevasses ça devient insupportable
et beaucoup trop dangereux donc ce qu'on
va faire c'est qu'on va mettre tous nos
vivres et nos ressources vitales sur un
traîneau qui sera à l'arrière et qui
sera dirigée par dean iska la moins
bonne visibilité du groupe le deuxième
prénom lui sera à l'avant on y mettra
tout notre matériel et sera dirigé par
xavier qui sera chargée de checker
autour et prévenir ninis y voit une
crevasse honnêtement c'est malin et
comme tous les gens dans ces histoires
ils ont une capacité d'adaptation assez
folle face à ce qui les entoure et grâce
à ça ils ont déjà parcouru 500 km et ils
sont à deux doigts d'atteindre leur
destination et de faire demi tour pour
rentrer à la base mais
calmez vous le 13 décembre 1912 ils sont
en train de marcher et xavier aperçoit
une crevasse au milieu de la neige il
lève le poing ils alertent le groupe il
contourne la crevasse et il continue son
chemin quelques minutes plus tard il se
retourne pour dire un truc à douglas et
y constate que derrière douglas ya plus
une hélice immédiatement ils font demi
tour ils marchent pendant plusieurs
minutes en hurlant son nom et puis
atteignent la fameuse crevasses que
xavier avait repéré quelques minutes
plus tôt et au fond de cette crevasse se
trouve le corps de deux chiens et le
traîneau en revanche nice ne se trouve
pas au fond de la crevasse douglas et
xavier vont chercher ce jour là pendant
plusieurs heures et ils ne vont jamais
le retrouver ils ne savent pas ce qui
est arrivé à nice ils ont des théories
peut-être qu'il est tombé dans la
crevasse qu'il est mort sur le coup et
que son corps est au fin fond de la
crevasse et n'est donc pas visible
depuis la surface peut-être aussi qu'il
est tombé qu'il est juste blessé et
qu'il a essayé de remonter à la surface
via un autre chemin bref ils n'en savent
rien tout ce qu'ils savent c'est que
leur amie a disparu et qu'il le
retrouverons jamais douglas et xavier
sont donc au milieu d'un environnement
extrêmement hostile à 100 100 km de la
base avec plus aucune nourriture ils
sont clairement foutu mais c'est des
explorateurs c'est des guerriers et ils
prennent tout de suite les choses en
main mais avant toute chose nouveau
problème souvenez-vous le bateau leur
aura quittent le camp le 15 janvier il
leur reste donc un mois pour parcourir
les 500 km retour et atteindre le bateau
ils font le tour de toutes les options
et malheureusement il y en a que deux la
première c'est rejoindre la côte où il
pourrait se nourrir des phoques donc
régler le problème de nourriture et
espérer tomber sur un autre groupe
d'explorateurs malheureusement la côte
elle à 500 km de leur position et pour y
aller c'est le même genre de chemin que
ce qu'ils viennent de faire c'est des
crevasses partout et rien d assure une
fois sur place de trouver de l'aide la
deuxième option c'est de couper par les
terres ce qui leur permettrait
d'atteindre la base beaucoup plus
rapidement et d'éviter tous les reliefs
dangereux les crevasses et c'est le
problème de cette option la section
chemin il y aura aucun animal à chasser
double a choisi la deuxième option et
pour résoudre ce problème de nourriture
il a une solution manger les chiens le
lendemain matin la fin se faire sentir
ils sont épuisés et il se résigne à
abattre un premier chien ils mangent
donc ce premier chien et c'est un moment
horrible puisque déjà la viande est
dégueulasse et en plus c'était un
compagnon de route vous plaît à voir des
animaux ben voilà imaginer demain vous
devez tuer votre chat ou votre chien
pour manger voilà bref vous avez compris
les jours passent et tous les jours
c'est la même chose c'est ce truc
macabre d'un battre un chien et de
manger pour pouvoir survivre mais on
arrive au stade où il n'y a plus assez
de chiens pour tirer les traînées
douglas et xavier doivent le pousser à
la force de leurs bras ce qui les épuise
et donc pour limiter la casse ils vont
se débarrasser de tout le matériel
inutile les instruments scientifiques
les fusils l'appareil photo tout ce qui
est inutile à leur survie et abandonné
le 29 décembre les deux hommes à battre
leur dernier chien et vu qu'ils sont
débarrassés de leurs fusils cette fois
c'est au couteau qui la bat ils ont plus
tiré donc plus nourriture il pousse même
le traîneau et du coup ils progressent
plus que de 8 km par jour autrement dit
laura sera parti bien avant qu'ils
atteignent le camp si jamais réussi à
l'atteindre là on se dit bon ils sont
plus bas et il peut arriver que du bien
maintenant nouveau problème xavier ton
gravement malade et son état ne cesse de
se détériorer faut savoir que pendant
toute l'expédition douglas prend des
notes dans son carnet et ce jour-là
douglas il explique dans son carnet que
nuit régulièrement des avis et se
réveille et hurle pendant des heures le
7 janvier xavier craque complètement
comme chaque nuit il se réveille comme
chaque nuit ils lui ont pendant des
heures mais cette nuit là ils essaient
de détruire la bri qui permet aux deux
hommes de survivre lors des nuits
glaciales douglas tentent de le
maîtriser se jettent sur lui s'allonge
sur lui le bloc xavier fini par se
calmer et apparemment quelques heures
après cet incident xavier lâche son
dernier souffle les scientifiques
pensent avec le recul quand fait en
mangeant les fois des chiens et
s'empoisonner à petit feu à cause d'une
abondance de vitamine à qui et à haute
dose toxique pour l'homme donc non
seulement il était déjà dans la merde
mais qu'en plus ce qu'ils mangent et ça
les affaiblissent et au final puisque
c'est les empoisonner bref où on en est
de ce calvaire douglas est maintenant
seul et il estime qu'il est à environ
160 kilomètres de la base alors il sait
qu'il atteindra pas le bateau attend
mais il espère qu avant de partir les
explorateurs laisseront au camp des
provisions au cas où douglas atteignent
le camp par miracle douglas continue de
marcher seul il a probablement plus
longtemps à vivre devant lui et un jour
une énorme douleur le prend au pied il
retire ses bottes pour voir ce qui se
passe et là il voit tranquillement la
plante de ses pieds se décoller la
douleur évidemment est insoutenable et
décide de bidouiller un truc pour avoir
moins mal il met de la cire sur son pied
il met plein de paires de chaussettes
qui remet sa botte et x10 pitié ça tient
il parle de la peau de son pied la pitié
satire malgré tout il réussit à
parcourir 8 km de plus dans cet état on
est le 17 janvier et la devinez quoi
nouveau problème il n'a pas le droit de
souffler douglas apparemment la
naissance on lui a dit toi jamais tu
respires fallait bien que ça arrive il
tombe dans une crevasse heureusement la
corde qui le reliait à son traîneau n'a
pas cédé le traîneau est toujours à la
surface et douglas réussi avec ses
dernières forces à remonter la corde
atteindre son traîneau et de nouveau
pouvoir reprendre sa route dix jours
plus tard bonne nouvelle une bonne
nouvelle les gars c'est pas une blague
douglas aperçoit au loin un petit
monument de pierre posée au milieu de
rien c'est petit monument de pierre
c'est une façon utilisée par les
explorateurs pour se laisser des
messages et le message en l'occurrence
est plutôt cool un groupe de son
expédition est apparemment actuellement
à sa recherche
et avec le message se trouvent de la
nourriture
le message date d'à peine six heures ça
veut dire que leur aura le bateau n'est
pas encore parti que les gens
d'expédition ne l'ont pas encore
abandonné clairement il retrouve
l'espoir et retrouve l'énergie
malheureusement le temps presse la date
à laquelle leur aura devais partir est
maintenant passé et il risque donc de
partir à tout moment avant des
prisonniers de la glace cause d'un
blizzard douglas est ralentie et
arrivent plus tard que prévu au camp et
à son arrivée il voit le groupe très
loin l'horizon en train de se bat alors
qu'est ce qui s'est passé le 8 février
trois semaines après le départ
initialement prévu l'équipage n'ayant
aucun signe de vie de douglas a décidé
de partir mais six hommes se sont portés
volontaires au moment du départ pour
rester au camp au cas où douglas
seraient encore vivants eux c'est
vraiment des beaux gosses comment je
serai sûr l'aurora à moi à leur place ou
douglas finit donc par croiser les six
hommes en question et vous ensemble
passer l'hiver à la base avec assez de
provisions pour survivre en attendant le
retour du bateau un an après son départ
leur aura revient donc chercher les sept
hommes au cap denisot et c'est la fin de
l'horreur pour douglas ça c'est une
bonne nouvelle waouh douglas n'a pas
traversé toutes les épreuves pour rien
il s'en sort vivant en inde m pas sûr
mais vivant à son retour en australie il
est accueilli comme un héros ça devient
une telle fierté nationale que ça
peut-être se retrouvent sur des billets
de 100 $ pendant plusieurs années c'est
bon sachez que malgré tout ça douglas
est retourné plusieurs fois en
antarctique pour des missions
chez même pas quoi dire je peux pas vous
laisser sur ce dénouement soit vous
parlez de certaines théories il ya un
arc très sombre de cette histoire qui a
été soulevée par des journalistes à
l'époque comment douglas a survécu après
avoir abattu son dernier chien certains
l'ont accusé de cannibalisme oui il ya
des rumeurs qui disent qu'il a dû
bouffer xavier d'ailleurs dans son
fameux journal de bord il ya un passage
un peu chelou un passage dans lequel il
dit j'ai fait bouillir de la viande de
chien mais la date correspond à deux
semaines après qu'il ait abattu le
dernier et deux jours après la mort de
xavier était ce bien du chien dans cette
casserole douglas on était ce dû xavier
évidemment les théories vont encore plus
loin certains vont jusqu'à dire que il
aurait précipité la mort de xavier en
tout cas lui de son vécu il a toujours
nié ces hypothèses et sa descendance les
nids à son tour aujourd'hui mais
l'hypothèse existe elle est intrigante
et quand même quand on voit les dates
des événements se dit comment tu as fait
a précédé hypothèses ça n'enlève rien à
son mérite d'avoir survécu à hotan dans
merde autant de galères franchement beau
gosse sacré explorateurs le douglas
écoute et j'espère que cette histoire
vous a plu moi je me cache pas je dois
être en laye dans six minutes
actuellement j'ai un peu tardé j'ai
kiffé vous raconter cette histoire
j'espère qu'elle vous a plu un gros
respect à tous les gens qui partent à
l'aventuré même dans des conditions pas
du tout aussi extrême je trouve ça assez
fou les gens qui mr pendant plusieurs
semaines au bouge dans des pays qui
connaissent pas du tout avec trois fois
rien juste un sac je trouve ça
incroyable ça demande un courage dingue
moi ça me terrorise et donc je suis
particulièrement touché par les
histoires comme celle de douglas
l'escudo sportez vous bien on se
retrouve bientôt une prochaine vidéo